en el segundo invitado del día
hablaremos de la actualidad política en
argentina que está marcada por la
polarización sobre todo tras el intento
de asesinato contra cristina fernández
de kirchner líder del peronismo ex
presidenta y vicepresidenta y es que
fernando sabah montiel le puso una
pistola en la cabeza la semana pasada y
aunque apretó el gatillo ninguna de las
balas salió desde entonces han rodado
decenas de explicaciones desde que el
atacante no supo usar el arma hasta que
el ex presidente se salvó de milagro
pero lo cierto es que este episodio
dividió todavía más a argentina y es que
fernández se enfrenta a varios procesos
judiciales en su contra en uno de ellos
la fiscalía pidió 12 años de cárcel y
prohibirle ocupar cargos públicos de por
vida presuntamente por favorecer una
millonaria contratación a favor de uno
de sus amigos para analizar la difícil
coyuntura que atraviesa argentina
conectamos con eduardo fidanza él es
director de poliarquía consultores
señor eduardo bienvenido a france 24
cuéntenos qué ha pasado con el atacante
las especulaciones alrededor del caso
clara
bueno el hecho conmovió del antiguo y en
un contexto
busca política
regida por lo que llamamos a la grieta
es decir posiciones de sectores críticos
paralizados que niegan la legitimidad
de sus adversarios
en ese contexto ocurrió un hecho inédito
a la argentina los últimos años pero que
activa de alguna manera la memoria de la
violencia que la argentina vivió
principalmente en la década de 1970 en
este momento y al igual que sucedió en
el caso del fiscal misma que en este
caso si él falleció no está clara la
la motivación tampoco está claro si se
trata de lo que se llama el caso en un
logo solitario o bien
tuvo cómplices en la realización de este
atentado fallido de manera que debemos
esperar en las próximas horas si la
investigación policial y de la justicia
revela o esclarecer de alguna manera el
hecho lo cierto es que la reacción de
buena parte de la sociedad que tira no
de toda la sociedad sino de lo que
llamamos minorías intensas ha sido una
interpretación a favor de sus propios
intereses políticos y responsabilizando
a los sectores adversarios por este
hecho así que estamos en un compás de
espera conveniencia y dumbría y por
cierto con estas preocupaciones
y si bien no se conocen las causas del
atentado hablemos más de estas
consecuencias que ustedes ya poco
comenzó a mencionar concretamente cómo
usaron los peronistas y sus detractores
este atentado
bueno
desde el punto de vista del oficialismo
del peronismo ellos se establecen una
causalidad que es muy difícil de
demostrar que es decir lo que ellos
llaman discursos de odio por parte de
los medios de comunicación de la
oposición y de sectores que se oponen al
gobierno que estos llamados discursos de
odio hubieran provocado
este atentado en verdad cuando uno
analiza los atentados que han ocurrido
en el mundo uno encuentra los más
diversos casos cierto de modo que esta
vinculación entre discursos de odio y
este intento es un intento de magnicidio
no nos queda claro por otro lado la
oposición política y los que están en
contra del gobierno
actual donde tiene 15% es el líder
principal
atribuyen esto o rechazan esta
interpretación y qué
la oposición con los medios de
comunicación han promovido este hecho
hay que generar algo cuando se habla de
discursos de odio aquí nunca en general
se habla de exterminar físicamente a
ningún adversario ni ha habido en los
últimos 40 años de democracia con alguna
excepción aislada en este tipo de
acciones ahora lo que está claro esto
enrarece el clima político argentino y
hay que agregar elementos del contexto
por un lado la profunda crisis económica
que atraviesa la argentina con una
inflación récord en el mundo con pérdida
de reservas en el banco central y todo
tipo de consecuencias sociales y hay que
reparar en la situación de la sociedad
que pone al tope de los problemas que la
preocupan la cuestión de la inflación la
cuestión del trabajo la cuestión de la
seguridad frente a delitos lo que lo
interrumpo eduardo porque quiero volver
a un punto que usted mencionó
en los medios de comunicación en
argentina que han sido el centro de la
polémica y después de este ataque
también se ha visto cómo reaccionaron y
ha habido también bastantes críticas
sobre todo por un artículo que publicó
el clarín que fue una infografía de cómo
activar correctamente un arma cómo cayó
esto en argentina
bueno a ver lo que hay que entender que
que hay en este clima de enfrentamiento
también hay medios de comunicación no
todos pero hay de comunicación alineado
con una u otra facción entonces si uno
por ejemplo
[Música]
toma la televisión prende la televisión
y va pasando los distintos canales va a
encontrar unos canales de televisión que
sistemáticamente atacan al gobierno y
otros que los defienden así también esto
se replica en la prensa escrita y por
cierto en las redes sociales de manera
yo no podría decir cómo se emplea en el
dicho que en una guerra la primera
víctima es la verdad hay analistas
políticos
respetables en la argentina que pueden
plantear de hecho la situación más
objetivamente pero esto se pierde por el
nivel de virulencia este que es cada
sector plantea y que además se resta
explica en los medios de comunicación
quiero decir tampoco supuestamente
causalidad entre medios de comunicación
y este atentado pero efectivamente los
medios de comunicación
amplifican el clima de enfrentamiento
político en la argentina no todos pero
varios que son muy significativos y muy
seguidos